thank you very much good evening
councillors
ladies and gentlemen and welcome to this
virtual online meeting of trafford full
council
um we'll start with apologies
um i think one's on his way all members
of council have been invited to attend
this meeting
electronically um we've had apologies
for absence from
councillors carey lam rigby
stenit and london have i missed anybody
that everyone miss samir i'm not i don't
see counselor her dad's name though and
i don't know if she's apology or if she
just can't get through
uh future uh please cancel that i can
see cancer
on the screen
smashing um in that case
um could i remind everyone when
participating in today's virtual meeting
please remember
to mute your microphone when not
speaking
uh to use the chat facility and zoom to
indicate to me that you wish to speak
and please only use the chat facility
for that purpose
um not commenting on the weather or the
price of fish
um and to unmute your microphone when
invited to speak
by me so
on that also on the subject of voting
um tonight on those items where a vote's
called for
um we're intending to vote on matters
using the polling option
on zoom um so at the appropriate time
i'll announce that
i'm putting a matter to the vote a
window will appear on your screen and
you will be asked to click one of three
options available
for against an abstain obviously so once
you've selected your preference please
click submit at the bottom of the window
and the outcome of the vote will appear
on the screen once
all the votes are in and finally
since we're hosting the meeting
virtually should we encounter any
technical difficulties
it may be necessary to adjourn in the
first instance for 15 minutes
uh and an update and any rejoining
instructions will be emailed to members
if we're unable to broadcast the meeting
live on youtube we'd
hope to upload it the recording of it at
a later date
um my laptop is slightly ropey so it is
possible that i will
um stop being heard at some stage some
people may say that's an improvement
but um fabio will let me know i'm sure
should that occur um so with that
um item one minutes the first item and i
move that the minutes of the council
meeting held on
meetings held on the 18th of march 15th
of
may and 14th of july 2020
be taken as read and signed as a correct
record
is that seconded please mr matt
thank you leader all in favor please
and the objections oh good
right moving on then item two
announcements
um i just want to say that um
on everyone's behalf um i attended um
last
no yes last month um a wreath-laying
ceremony to commemorate the
vj day um the 75th uh
anniversary of that at sail uh war
memorial
obviously that was a very moving event
it's a shame we couldn't uh market as
i'm sure we would have liked
but um i went to that on your behalf and
also this month
um the marist the deputy mayor and the
deputy mayor s and i
uh attended um a commemoration of the
80th anniversary of the battle of
britain again at sale war memorial
um again that was very moving and um i'm
sure very well received
but again it's just a shame we couldn't
mark it in the way i'm sure we would all
have liked to
um moving on ultringham fc noting that
this is the first council meeting giving
me the opportunity
um to recognize the club's achievements
in the summer uh
i'm sure would you like to join me in
congratulating ultraman football
club on promotion to the national league
after their victories in the playoffs
um which is very good news um
does the leader of the council wish to
make any announcements this evening
councillor weston
uh no thank you mr man thank you
councillor acton have you anything to
announce on behalf of the pandemic
scrutiny committee
counselor acton
he's gone quiet
is he there he told me
sorry mr mayor um yes
just to announce that um we we
have agreed to have two uh budget
meetings
uh to scrutinize the executives
budget proposals and all members are
welcome to
join us in that okay miss matt
thank you very much councillor acton um
moving on item three questions i can
report that five questions have been
submitted for tonight's meeting
from councillors myers coggins newgrosh
brophy and miss blackburn each of the
questions
will be dealt with without discussion in
the order they were received
in respect of questions one four and
five a written response has been
provided and published
on the website i would ask the exact
members concern just to summarize it in
a couple of sentences if they can
um and once that's done i'll move
straight to the supplementary question
if
any um so question one counselor myers
your question please
yes thank you mr mayor the council has
agreed to borrow
up to half a billion pounds to invest in
properties
that will generate revenue and support
regeneration
now most of the investment has been
pre-covered and much of investment has
been in retail premises
which are now worth considerably less
than the price actually paid
in addition the empty retail premises
have left a shortfall in revenue
would the executive member for finance
investment outline the strategy to
mitigate the losses
thank you mr mayor
councillor ross thank you mr mayor and
thank you councillor myers for your
question um my
summary in response is as follows all
the council's investments have been made
in accordance with the agreed investment
strategy and are monitored closely with
regular regular updates provided to the
investment management board
the range of investments is both diverse
across a number of sectors and comprises
a mix of investments
including directly acquired assets and
provision of development debt
of the amounts invested at the end of
2019-20
approximately 25 percent had a direct
retail exp exposure
and one quarter of that is invested in
supermarkets
real estate valuations rise and fall
over time with the normal
market cycles however as the council is
a long-term investor
portfolio income levels are more
significant than on paper value
these investments provide an important
revenue stream to the council
services and are estimated to generate a
net income of 7.4 million during this
budget year
thank you mr mayor thank you councillor
ross
and as i've been mentioned a detailed
written reply
is available on the website uh
councillor myers do you have a
supplementary question please
say i do it mr mayor um i'm grateful for
councillor bosta's response
and the details about 100 million pounds
that's been invested in the falling
retail market can you tonight assure the
council that the 3.9
million pounds reserve to which he
refers to in his response
is enough to plug the potential black
hole thank you mr mayor
ross please you always keep our reserves
on regular review and actually we've
been looking to increase the uh
the reserve we have put aside for the
investment management strategy
so it's as i say as far as i am
concerned at the moment you have my
assurance but it is always subject to
further review and we will review it if
we need to in future
thank you thank you councillor ross um
councillor coggins would you care to put
your question please
thank you chair council agree that
two years which would have been 18
months without the pandemic is not an
appropriate time scale for an emergency
response
like the reply we have had to the
climate emergency motion this week
thank you for your question councillor
coggins would counselor ads head
exec member for environment air quality
and climate change respond
please thank you uh mr mayor hopefully
you can hear me
and uh thank you for your question
councillor coggins
trafford was one of the first councils
to declare a climate emergency
addressing the change of climate
addressing the challenge of climate
change
and the need to eliminate our use of
carbon is not a straightforward task
and nor is that a task that can be
achieved by the council alone
requires the support of traffic
businesses communities
and residents the council commissioned
external experts and thesis
to support us in developing our
framework and their report has been well
received and was approved
at executive earlier this month setting
ourselves the target
of achieving carbon neutrality by 2038
it should be noted that their work would
have concluded
much earlier in the year had it not been
for the effect
of covert 19 and the consequences in
terms
of the support required for the council
response
but the ability to engage with partners
the importance
of meeting the climate challenge is
recognised
as one of our corporate priorities and
the council
has brought forward initiatives to
reduce carbon usage
such as our investment in traffic
metrolink
active travel proposals tree planting
schemes and the clean air plan
council will note how
we are now leading the way on
sustainable development
with the proposals we have brought
forward with bruntwood
for the redevelopment of the former
kellogg's headquarters
these are able these all demonstrate our
commitment to addressing the climate
emergency
now the framework has been agreed i look
forward to working across the council
and with partners to deliver our
ambitious plans
thank you mr mayor
thank you councillor ad said for your
response
counselor coggins do you have a
supplementary question please i i do
thank you chair
um given the bewildering positive
reception to this very stark news um at
exec
and that the independent report from
anticipate
the decisive window for action is small
and rapidly closing
the council must adopt a more proactive
approach
and view the response to this agenda as
a higher priority
than previously from the independent
experts not the green party
has the executive really truly grasped
the extent of the challenge that faces
us
and the implications for us all if we
fail
brad said counselor outside please
thank you mr mayor and councillor
corkins for your supplementary
council of cognitive yes of course if
you'd have uh obviously you have read
the report that went to excessive
on monday and of course the details are
there i think a task now
because i did indicate it says start
setting up as a matter of urgency
the various groups we need to do this
and forums these will include
businesses ones for councillors and ones
for communities and the like
and i think that will actually help set
up a task in that one we certainly do
grasp
how difficult it's going to be by
certain means obviously the report did
indicate we'd had a
positive uh some little positive
progress over the last couple years
however that is small and there's
certainly a lot in front of us i think
there's a lot of way to do you'll also
note as well
that obviously we're now starting uh at
the uh the gm
uh level as well now those meetings
being set up there to
implement the five-year plan and that is
progressing that partnership
uh is now kicking off on the ground so i
think we need to get all these people
together there's a lot of work to do
but it does start now so i think thank
you mr mayor that's why
thank you for your concise response
though um councillor outside
um in that case we move on councillor
newgross
could you put your question please
thank you mr mayor my question is
with the first anniversary of trafford's
council's empty homes policy upon us
can we please be informed exactly how
many long-term
empty homes have been brought back into
use by this initiative
and what the current number of long-term
empty homes
currently stands out
would counsellor write the executive
member for housing and regeneration
respond please uh thank you mr mayor
the council published its empty property
strategy
in november 2019 to confirm the method
for dealing with the problem of empty
properties in trafford
empty properties are a wasted resource
when housing is needed across trafford
they are often a source of antisocial
behavior and nuisance and can adversely
affect
neighborhoods the teams primarily
involved in the implementation of the
strategic strategies
are housing standards exchequer services
and planning enforcement
the first stage in the implementation of
the strategies was to assess the number
of long-term
empty properties within the borough
which will require further
investigation the initial review
of long-term empty properties was based
upon data obtained from the council tax
team
with a criteria of properties declared
empty for two
over two years excluding empty
properties due to the death of residents
those in prison or hospital and those
where person libel is residing in a care
home or hostel
the number of properties which met this
criteria was 487
as of june 2020 a further detailed
review of the properties was undertaken
to identify properties
which may already be known to the
council's been empty
that may be in process of being sold or
renovated
or were indeed actually occupied and did
not need further intervention
this review confirmed 445 properties
being empty over two years
with no excavate explanation and no
details of potential plans to bring them
back into use
these are the properties where the
owners are most likely leaving them
empty on purpose these properties are
located across the borough
but highest density is in sale stretford
altering them
and ermstan to identify the properties
which are creating the most problems a
risk assessment
has been developed for each empty
property
this includes property condition asb
associated
with the property complaints or the
other voids nearby
inspections of the properties are
ongoing at present
when the inspections and reviews are
complete
problem properties will be identified
and subject for further scrutiny
enforcement
action such as statutory notices to
clear gardens
and improve for cades enforced
sale of properties and compulsory
purchase orders
as of the 30th of september this year
63 inspections have under have been
undertaken of empty properties
the housing standards team also make
available small loans available for
owners of empty properties
up to ten thousand pounds and this has
been communicated
to owners of entry properties on a
regular basis
through regular mail shots for several
years
however at this time uptake has been low
two properties in 1920 were brought back
into use using this financial assistance
part of the strategy actions is to
identify why uptake of the financial
assistance has been so low
the housing standards team are also
dealing with complaints about
empty properties and regularly take
enforcement action to secure properties
and deal with nuisances
in 1920 the housing standards
team investigated complaints concerning
99 empty properties in trafford
and this resulted in the risk in the
service of 39 enforcement notices
to deal with open to access problems and
nuisances
associated with empty properties in
november 2020 the first yearly review of
trafford empty property strategy will be
undertaken
and a further update at that stage can
be provided
thank you mr mayor
right um councillor new gross do you
have a supplementary question
i don't think he answered my first
question was that two properties
councillor
sorry can i be clear
two properties using the financial
assistance yes that's correct
i'll let you have that counselor new
growth do you have a supplementary uh
the supplementary would be i mean
in your housing strategy you listed over
700
empty long-term home homes
and now counting 487 i
i don't understand how you've nearly
halved it
um by by what means and
you have brought two back into use in
the first year
um i'm i'm sorry if i'm wrong here but
this is
very very poor it's it's even it's far
worse
the conservatives manage sixteen percent
in that counselor
i think we've got the idea of your
question counselor right would you care
to ask
answer please uh yeah so it's 445
um actually um with the with the figures
and and a couple of things i would just
mention on that front is that
two may have come back into use by the
financial assistance fund however
um we are as we've already state as i've
already stated
investigating and visiting these
properties
um over a period of time to look into
them into more detail
um i think it's slightly unfair of you
to say that um
it's not a particularly good uh response
given that we've
obviously gone through a a world crisis
uh this year concerning um uh housing
and empty properties and obviously that
has caused
us to divert resources to other affairs
in the council
number one but also made visiting
properties equally difficult
so i think it's rather harsh of you to
say that
um that it's it's not a particularly
great response obviously we would like
it to be
better than it is and it is a priority
for the council i can assure you of that
um and hopefully in a
in better times we may be able to get
this moving in a quicker fashion
um but given the restrictions that we
are under at the moment with covid
i think it is very difficult to push
this um
to a greater degree than we already are
thank you mr mayor
thank you councillor right councillor
brophy would you care to put your
question please sure there
counselor brophy
are you there
i am here thank you mr mayor i am here
please put your question
thank you mr mayor what additional
services can trafford provide
for people experiencing mental health
challenges during covid
whether that be due to exacerbation of
previous mental health issues
or needs to happen as a result of the
covet virus itself
or things such as ongoing or worsening
physical health issues
including unemployment isolation
depression or loneliness or any other
reason
thank you councillor brophy as has been
mentioned councillor slater has provided
a written reply for that to this council
of slavery would you just care to
quickly summarise that please
yes thank you mr mayor um
councillor brophy you will notice um
it's quite a lengthy submission that
i've provided
and and with speaking to greater
manchester mental health
services and i'd like to just point out
that you know when you've asked about
additional services to support people
during the pandemic
and the service did look to
provide skype telephone and microsoft
teams and meetings with people who
needed to access services
as well as the the normal mental health
services that are provided by our
service providers
also you've asked around whether you
know
physical uh things have become worse due
to unemployment and all those sort of
things
the the mental health services have
stepped up um
around that and psychological therapy
services
have provided um so that have provided
services for people to speak about
loneliness
unemployment stress sleep trauma because
we've had so much domestic violence
that's taken place during lockdown
which you know it's been unprecedented
some of the um some of that some of
those
assaults that have happened uh and
obviously they have been at the
forefront of supporting our residents
around
that and also with the uh volunteer hub
the primary care mental health and
wellbeing service has worked really
closely with our
and volunteer hubs in the neighborhood
and they have actually
um taken referrals from the hubs have
supported people via the hubs
so that has been and you know that has
been uh welcome
and our one of our providers blue sky
and who we commissioned to do some of
that work has has stepped up and done
uh extra work around around that also
the approved mental health professionals
our amps have worked continuously
throughout the code video and
pandemic um our adult and autism and
services
and our map services they were actually
stepped down for a little while because
those
those staff were actually required to
work on the front line we've had lots of
staff who had been working in
the hospital who have had to go to work
on the front line to support the covered
wards
but i'd like to let you know that those
services now have um
all been stepped back back up and are
running as normal
and also the trust provides a 24-hour
helpline
and i think it'd be really helpful if
all counsellors noted that helpline
and uh you know so that they had that
ready for residents who contacted them
and if they needed that support it's for
service users and their carers and i'll
if is it okay mr mayor if i read that
number down and people want to jot
it down so the number is zero
eight zero zero nine
five three zero two
eight five so um i think the rest of the
information is uh covers everything else
in the question thank you mr mayor
thank you very much councillor slater
councillor brophy do you have a
supplementary question please
first i'd like to thank councillor jane
slater for her very
detailed answer and for all the work
she's personally done
to provide that and i think what's
coming across
from what i'm hearing is that we're
facing
as well as the covert challenge there's
what's called a tsunami of
mental health issues out there in the
community
you're very quiet counsellor brophy you
might need to turn yourself
up can you hear me now i've got the
microphone
in front of me i've had to switch
computers because my trafford computer
wouldn't allow me
to access but here goes so my
supplementary question is
so we know that we're facing as well as
the covid challenge
we're also facing a tsunami of
exacerbation and
mental health challenges out there in
the community we know that
um so my question is i can hear the
answer that trafford is doing everything
possible you're a lot easing with all
the relevant services
my question is are you confident
that as trafford council that these
needs can be met in unprecedented times
with all the challenges we're
additionally facing to our funding
and pressures on other services and
people being deployed elsewhere
as you outlined in your answer and thank
you counselors later
sorry mr mayor was going right across
and staff have been deployed in other
areas to support covid on the front line
but obviously as as our hospitals have
been able to discharge people from
covered wards
people have been able to move back to
their own jobs so the staff are backing
back in situ um i do i do feel confident
with
what the staff are telling me that is
taking place and obviously what
residents are telling me about services
that they are
and engaging with i do feel confident
that we are providing
as much as we possibly can provide as an
authority
when we have massive budget pressures
you know the nhs has
also has massive budget pressures we've
been in a situation
since 2010 you know we um you know we
had the coalition initially
and then we've had um continuous um cuts
from um
the tory government for the last 10
years so on in those circumstances
i you know i feel as confident as i
possibly can
that we are doing everything we can but
on a budget
that is getting cut and cut every year
and it's the people at the bottom of the
pile
that suffer and that you know so we're
doing we're doing what we can with the
little bit that we've got so
yeah i do feel confident and you know
i'd like to thank all the staff
that have been involved in these
services over the last few months
because they've all stepped up
they've all been absolutely amazing and
then what do we get again we you know
we're offered
further cuts and from from government so
you know
if you all can just lobby your mps and
get us some more money that would be
brilliant
thank you um
councillor miss blackburn would you care
to put your question please
uh thank you mr mayor um would the exact
number for environment air quality
and climate change inform me as to the
legal maximum width of cycle lanes and
if advanced notice of them
on roads needs to be given to road users
thank you councillor ms blackburn
councillor ad said would you care to
just
briefly summarize your written answer
please thank you mr mayor
and councillor blackburn for your
question which i did provide a full
written
and detailed response on the diagram
that explained the
example of actually how one can look so
i won't go through that in detail
i'll simply give a couple of quick
points from that one there is no legal
maximum width for cycle lanes if a
highway authority
makes a decision to have a whole
cabbageway deadly cycles only
it can do so by introducing a
prohibition of motor vehicles or
pedestrians and cycles etc
and these are usually enforced with
signs or physical measures
and whilst you will note there is no
legal maximum there is of course
a legal minimum wage when you look at
the department of transport
infrastructure and design work so so
hopefully that answers that part of it
and there's a detailed design of it on
your second point
there is there are no advanced cycle
lanes so
there are no advanced lane signs
permitted to be used on the highway and
again that is following the ft guidance
on that one
thank you mr mayor councillor ad said
council ms blackburn do you have a
supplementary question uh yes please mr
mayor
um could um counselor ads uh
uh specify what safeguards um are you
undertaking to ensure that
at road junctions where there are cycle
lanes
that safety is prioritized for all road
users as it present the pop-up cycle
lane on the a56 has created hazards
thank you mr mayor yes sir on the on
cycle lane
particularly we've been working very
close with transport for greater
manchester
and we were getting uh very regular
updates on our specs of it in addition
to this our young teams have been
reviewing this very very regular and a
lot of issues have been dealt with
as and when they've come along and as
sometimes issues have also been raised
with in other methods as well
through contributions from either public
members all the right
and where those issues been raised have
been looked and addressed so if you have
any further concerns on particular
locations then please do let us know
that
and we'll have to look at them for you
thank you mr mayor you counselor adds
head
uh moving on then item four council and
committee meetings arrangements format
and timetable
before i invite councillor freeman to
introduce this item
i just need to report two updates to the
report that's been actually circulated
um firstly there's a typo in
recommendation two
um the planning and development control
committee has proposed to continue at
the 4 pm start time and not 4 30 p.m
and also the planning committee's
meeting on the 8th of october has been
put back a week and is arranged for the
15th of october
2020. so with those two comments
corrections noted can i then please
invite councillor freeman the executive
member for public safety governance and
reform
to introduce and move the report
councillor freeman please
thank you mr mayor and thank you for
pointing out the corrections to the
paper
the paper before council is
self-explanatory it
represents a resume of the work and
deliberations of the cross-party
constitution working group mr mayor we
continue to operate in what can only be
described as exceptional times
and i trust the council continues to
appreciate this
i would like to pay tribute to the hard
work of dedication displayed by our
council staff
in ensuring our meetings on the virtual
platforms continue to function
and rit staff are making this possible
council is asked to approve the
recommendations in the paper listed one
to five
i acknowledge that the continuation of
daytime meetings with some of our
members
apart from council meetings which have
now reverted to the evening
continues to cause them difficulty in
attending however
with the current lockdown restrictions
as they are and to ensure our council
staff will continue to be at the
forefront of the local response of this
pandemic
i ask the members understanding the
cross party constitution working group
will reconvene in december
to further review our meeting structures
and times i commend the paper to council
for approval thank you mr mayor
freeman is that seconded please secondly
did mr marin reserve the right thanks
thank you councillor weston um i have
two speakers noted
as usual if you could use the chat
function on zoom to indicate that you
wish to speak
um councillor evans first please uh
thank you councillor freeman i'd like to
echo your comments and
pay tribute to our officers members and
staff for the support of the past six
seven months and it's been unprecedented
and it is unprecedented times
but i'm afraid we we won't be able to
support this uh report is
it has become increasingly difficult for
the bulk of our members to attend these
meetings
um and it's in but kids have gone back
to school
and parents have obviously gone back to
work and and the bulk of our members
i just can't make the meetings as is
evident we we have fewer and fewer and
we are missing meeting
which isn't giving our residents the
support and it isn't giving the council
the scrutiny that it actually demands
so we won't be supporting this uh report
and we
again express we need to move back to um
later times our normal times as soon as
possible i do appreciate the problems of
that but
it's get we could be here in 12 months
time and and
things are not going to may not get any
better so we need to get back to those
times so we can at least
all and i suppose this must count for
some of the labor
members represent our residents fairly
thank you
councillor evans councillor anstey
please
uh thank you uh mr mayor um can i just
echo
some of the comments to the council if
we that council freeman has made in
relation to our staff and the
challenging circumstances within that
which they are working but can i also
point out that that what is true for
trafford council is truth
is true for every employee whether they
work in the public or private sector and
you've seen over the last
seven months you know people have had to
adapt to living with coronavirus i
totally accept the point
around in-person meetings and that would
be
very difficult to achieve at the moment
but clearly the technology
works and traffic council has a
long-standing
tradition of um engagement from all
members of all political
parties and i accept councillor freeman
your your commitment to that but
but six months ago we did make very
strong representations
when these arrangements were put in
place and that they
should be temporary and the very
definition of temporary is that
um and i i fear that having had
six or seven months now to consider what
new arrangements may be like
that an extra two months um is not
really going to make an awful lot of
difference between the choices that
could be
made so i'd welcome councillor freeman's
comments on
you know and so what at what point does
he envisage the authority moving back to
all members being able to participate
at 6 30 and one uh at 6 30 and 7 for
committee meetings and one
especially given the the choices that
the authority has to make
as we enter into budget setting season
there's budget scrutiny that is about to
commence we know that this budget is
going to be challenging and difficult
and therefore the active involvement of
all members in that is important and one
final point for me
mr mayor is in relation to one of the
comments in the report and it
refers to the difficulties in
additional time off in lieu um for
certain staff who would have to support
committee meetings in the evening
this council has just released workforce
proposals that allow
greater levels of time off for people
for our existing workforce if they
choose to take
it so and those two things don't square
very comfortably with me
because you cannot in the one hand argue
in a report
that a few hours for a committee meeting
is going to be so disruptive that you
can't do it and then at the same time
promote
significant workforce changes and so
there's a contradiction in what the
authority is wanting to do
and there is a willingness from all
members i think to support the work
that's been
undertaken and on our ability to do that
would be really appreciated
thank you mr mayor councillor thomas
please
thank you mr mayor uh item agenda two or
sorry item two you're very quiet simon
you might need to turn yourself up
i don't know if i can i'll sleep closer
too hope that's better that's a bit
better
recommendation recommendation two is
difficult for me as i
work full-time but we do have to take
the whole situation
as it is in trafford as a whole the rate
is
rising rapidly and i think that we have
to be
protective of all workers all members
going forward and that's why i'll
support this recommendation
[Music]
council thomas i have no further
indications councillor weston do you
wish to
reserve um bring out your speak yeah
thank you
mr mayor it is unfortunate that we have
conservative members saying that they
want to support our staff but when
presented with recommendations that do
that intend to
fail to support those i appreciate
and indeed councillor evans said himself
that there are likely to be members in
my group
impacted by this there are members in my
group impacted
by this but the impact on our staff
who have had six months of an
unprecedented crisis
who have been redeployed who have been
supporting in other areas
and who we would be asking to work in
their own homes
in the evening with their own families
often including young children
running around the place that is an
unfair pressure
to put on our staff in what are already
incredibly
strained times and without wishing to
stray too
far from the item mr mayor i do need to
respond to the particular point from
councillor anstey
who suggested that there was something
oxymoronic about both saying that
we should offer further flexible working
arrangements but say that time off in
lieu
is difficult in the current climate none
of us actually
would want to be offering the sort of
package that we've had to put to our
workforce council
and state this is as a result the
financial impact
of this crisis and the simple fact of
the matter is
that when we have a 37 and a half
million pound funding gap
next year 15 million plus of that as a
result of covered
we have to do things that are
unpalatable
to us this is the situation that we face
mr mayor
and there is absolutely no contradiction
in saying that we want to protect our
staff when putting
forward proposals such as that
protect jobs in this authority that is
what that measure does
that is what our proposals around the
workforce for the next financial year do
but they are not incompatible with this
report in any way
shape or form thank you mr matt
councillor freeman you have indicated
can you make it brief please
yes frankly that it's called a
cross-party constitution working group
and you had representation councillor
evans at that group
uh and frankly i'm quite appalled you've
come here tonight and said what you've
said
um and so again i just commend the paper
for
the council before approval thank you mr
mayor
freeman um i've had no further
indications um
i think we'll have to put this to a vote
fabiola is that uh
is it all we all set up to do that yes
mayor
when you're ready we are in which case
please put it to the vote
i will
[Music]
does everyone have the little box no
problems
councilman new gross you seem to be
indicating if you have got
problems is it not working
right okay let me not share uh when when
you want me to
tell you the results yeah councillor new
gross didn't get a box i'll be over
okay okay um
right so uh i'll look into it um
so we've got four 36
members of express in favor of uh
martian
we've got
okay yeah council new rush indicated in
the chat you've counted that haven't you
okay so okay thank you thank you
i'll share the results with you all
okay thank you fabiola that
recommendation is carried um
but if you could just have a look at
that fabio and try and find out why we
didn't
one member didn't get a box i will
always care thank you
moving on item five the accounts and
audit committee annual report
twenty nineteen twenty and before the
council has the accounts and audits
annual
report and i invite the chair of that
committee councillor brotherton to
introduce it councillor brotherton
please
thank you mr mayor uh members will have
seen the paper but
uh during the the uh 19
20 20 19 stroke 20 the committee
continued to provide
uh uh an independent uh assurance to the
council and to the wider public
about the uh the functioning of the
council's
finances we were caught by covid right
at the end in march
2020 that meeting had to be cancelled
and
since then though it's outside the scope
of this report we have been reviewing
our working practices and had at least
one meeting by zoom
and i'm sure unfortunately we'll
probably have to continue for for the
rest of the
the president financial year um
and the government have changed some of
the finance some of the limits about
when we have to submit various financial
reports as well which will
affect the work of the committee i'd
just like to
thank the members of the committee for
their support during the year and the
officers are particularly
mark foster and graham bentley for their
very helpful advice and support during
the year covered by this report thank
you chair
i think this is to be noted by the
committee by the council i hope they can
do so thank you
thank you councillor brotherton the
report is for noting is it seconded
please
i can do it miss mayer thank you
councillor lloyd
um do any counsellors wish to speak on
it nobody's indicated
no in which case
um we will note that report
thank you councillor brotherton
um moving on then item six the year-end
corporate report on health
safety and well-being 2019-20 i invite
councillor ross executive member for
finance and investment to introduce the
year-end corporate report
on health and safety councillor ross
please
thank you mr mayor the health safety and
well-being work streams of the health
and safety unit
in conjunction with services and
partners are detailed in the report
the report also briefly highlights the
initial supports provided to in response
to covert 19 which fell at the end of
the financial year
further analysis are covert 19 of
support will be detailed in the next
corporate health and safety
six-month report for april to september
2020. there have been a number of audits
as detailed in the report
in terms of accidents the overall total
number of accidents
for 2019-20 have significantly declined
from 174 incidents to 136
these are the lowest figures for over
the last four years
in terms of training and support a range
of comprehensive and
face-to-face and online training has
been provided to 745 colleagues
in terms of health and well-being a
range of health and well-being support
has continued to be delivered through
the employee health and well-being
strategy
2019-22 also known as epic
you um just going back to the um
the covid support um because i know this
may be a particular interest with uh
with with members
it's kobuto19 has brought significant
challenges for the council in protecting
the health safety and well-being of our
workforce
and the continuing delivery of frontline
services
key initial support at the end of our
financial year in 1920 included
health safety and well-being support and
guidance for colleagues working from
home
participation and support to a council
ppe team
for the procurement and distribution of
ppe to key services
the development of covid 19 risk
assessment templates and guidance for
our buildings schools
services and persons and greater risk
in conclusion the report has highlighted
a wide and varied range of health and
safety well-being
that's taken place support um and be
delivered across the organization
to support our workforce and partners
covert 19 will continue to heavily
impact on the sh and
on the work that was done during this
year and obviously that will be reported
on later thank you mr matt
is that report seconded please mr mayor
thank you
thank you councillor weston um i have
one indication councillor coggins would
you like to speak on this
thank you chair um i the last time we
looked at a report like this i brought
up an issue which i see has been
addressed and i just want to welcome
that change
um we had been using the term road
traffic accident
and and i did suggest that in line with
um
all those campaigning for safer and
camera streets
that we changed using the word road
traffic coalition and
i'm pleased to see that that change has
come in in this new report
the word accident of course implies that
there is nothing that can be done about
it
and and sadly we know that the high
number of injuries and
deaths on our roads um are a result of
political choices
made by government and by local councils
across the country
and it's really important that the
language that we use to describe that is
accurate and reflects the decisions that
we make and and and the repercussions
so i really want to welcome that change
thank you
anthony's councillor lally please
thank you mr mayor and it'd be
interesting to see what positive things
come out of kovit for for the following
year in this report and
and to do perhaps someone out further
analysis into
the figures that come out for the
following year because obviously
uh as as people have already indicated
it's completely different
uh this year and obviously domestic
violence is up would it be interesting
to understand
where people are venting their anger as
i not included in this report i don't
think
uh councilors is uh some of the phone
call
monitoring that we get through our
system so it'd be interesting to
understand
if there's been a rise in any particular
issues with
with our uh with our phone system and
and how residents have engaged with that
so that's probably something to to bear
in mind for next year will be
i've had no further indications the
report
is for noting so can we all note that
please
moving on item seven motions
this evening four motions have been
listed on the summons in the order that
were they were received
um the first is in respect of domestic
violence which was deferred from council
on the 18th of march this year and is to
be
moved by councillor new please
thank you mr mayor this motion is one
that labour groups are passionately in
support of
and i would like to thank my colleagues
councillors carter patel and carr for
their input into this document
i'm thankful for the opportunity to move
this motion and also
to speak a little about the true impact
of domestic violence
and the horrendous outcome of the if the
proposed early interventions
and consistent response and support
isn't in place
in partington two years ago this month a
baby boy was airlifted to hospital with
serious and life-threatening injuries
mum had gone to an early morning
doctor's appointment leaving her son in
the care of his father
when she returned life as she knew it
had been irreversibly destroyed
what transpired as her tiny son fought
for his life was a sickening
and sad with too many women familiar
pattern of domestic abuse
control and fear at the hands of her
partner who
by this time had been taken into police
custody for questioning regarding the
non-accidental injuries that the tiny
boy had sustained
two days later at 16 weeks of age one of
parkinson's youngest residents have died
he had put up an incredible fight but
his tiny body succumbed to the violence
that had overshadowed
every one of his 268 hours of life
in the days following neighbours
overcoming grief and feelings of guilt
began to speak out about the violence
shouting
and screaming that had been heard as
routine from the flat that the couple
had shared
of mum's distant silent weary appearance
of her reluctance to speak
when in the company of her partner and
of his pride in his son
mum would speak in court months later
that his train
of strangulation punches threats theft
of her bank card
emotional and verbal abuse having her
nails ripped out
drunk binges drunk and drug binges
where he would disappear for weeks at a
time and then return for the inevitable
come down
where she would pay the price for his
low mood all the time looking after her
young baby and older son
keeping a front of normality together
while feeling emotionally bereft
isolated and terrified of the man she
was sharing her life with
never once believing he was capable of
hurting his tiny son
the decision to leave her baby at home
with his father while making a short
visit to the doctors will haunt her for
the rest of her life
there is so much more to this one case
than i could possibly detail here
as there is to the 2 million
in this last year alone of which 1.6
million are women and while the council
note that all children are victims too
how many are seeing this
experiencing it and living in crippling
fear of it
how many lives have been psychologically
this is why as a council and as
individual members
we must do what we can do to promote
awareness
and to raise the profile of domestic
abuse across all partnerships
organizations and services to be that
safe person to approach in our
communities for help and advice in
accessing the traffic
partnership domestic and abuse strategy
and even more importantly to continue to
lobby parliament
to sustain funding for specialist
women's services
it took three years for the domestic
abuse bill to finally be brought to
parliament
and while we recognize and support this
for me
that's three years too long women
children
and men four hundred thousand last year
are suffering hurting and dying the last
three years
if those figures have been tragically
consistent that is six million cases
while waiting for this this bill to be
brought to parliament
none of us could have anticipated the
national lockdown we were plunged into
from march the 20th this year due to
coronavirus
the situation we were suddenly invented
victims were unable to escape violence
from
within their homes and restrictions cut
off escape routes
such as the school run and visits to
local shops and cases of domestic
violence increased
during the first three months of
lockdown more than 40
000 calls and contacts were made to the
national domestic abuse helpline
mostly by women seeking help and the
men's advice line
states that it received 8 500 calls in
those initial three months
while it is noted that the government
announced it would give an additional
two million pounds for domestic abuse
helplines
this came 19 days into the lockdown
statistics obtained from uk
police forces reveal that there was one
domestic abuse call every 30 seconds
in the first seven weeks of lockdown the
recorded calls
include reports of violent offences
kidnap revenge porn
arson rape and even poisoning the un has
described the worldwide increase in
domestic abuse as a shadow pandemic
alongside kovid 19.
as restrictions eased on what we must
keep up the pressure for long-term
funding strategies for domestic abuse
services
to continue to raise awareness of the
realities of domestic violence for all
impacted by it
and to ensure that there is support for
all victims to be able to move forward
in safety
mr mayor i would like to move this
motion in memory of baby
alfie with the blessing of his mum he
was born on the 14th of may 2018
and he tragically fell asleep in his
mum's arms on the
16 weeks later on the 14th of september
2018.
may he rest in peace thank you mr mayor
thank you councillor i understand the
motion will be seconded by councillor dr
carr councillor dr carr please
thanks mr mayor i second this motion in
my work
i sadly see victims of domestic abuse
regularly
like the young woman who had her fingers
broken one by one with a hammer
for attempting to report her violent
partner and was then run over
as she tried to run away or the woman
who had her teeth
pulled out with pliers or the woman who
was violently raped for asking her
partner
not to drink too much and it isn't just
physical abuse that leaves scars
long-term financial and emotional abuse
and threats of violence
can be just as terrifying without ever
having to leave a physical mark on the
victim
emotional abuse can take root over many
years
while the abuser gradually takes more
and more control of the victim
and often isolates them from friends or
relatives
this type of abuse is particularly
difficult to escape from
or even to recognize the abuse becomes
so effective that just a few words or
even a look
can result in absolute terror this
includes threats about
violence towards family members and
especially threats of violence towards
children
i also see other victims in my line of
work teenagers who have taken overdoses
after growing up in abusive households
young people who are homeless
because they've tried to escape an
abusive home
i know it isn't pleasant to hear stories
about domestic abuse
i'm sure you'd all rather not hear these
stories and it's very easy to think that
this is something
that we don't need to worry too much
about in wealthier parts of the borough
but this isn't just something that
happens in partington or ghost hill
domestic abuse is happening everywhere
it occurs across all sections of society
to all ethnic groups and towards both
women and men
some stark figures from the office for
national statistics
include the almost one in three women
aged 16 to 59
will experience domestic abuse in their
lifetime
two women a week are killed by a current
or former partner
in england and wales alone and 20 of
children in the uk
have lived with an adult perpetrating
domestic violence
so the chances are that a number of
people in this meeting will have
experienced abuse first
hand i myself was subjected to
domestic violence that occurred whilst
at university
i was lucky and had a supportive family
and despite threats and coercion
was able to get out of the violent and
unpredictable relationship
the covid19 pandemic unfortunately
has made the situation even worse for
victims of domestic abuse
financial uncertainty anxiety and
isolation have all had a profound
negative effect
domestic abuse is strongly associated
with heavy alcohol use
and this has skyrocketed over the
lockdown period
resulting in a toxic mix and making
victims more vulnerable than ever
i'm sure all of us are fed up of
lockdown none of us have enjoyed it
but for some lockdown has been a living
hell with constant exposure to an
abusive partner
this motion could make the difference to
victims and i urge all members to
support it
thank you dr carr councillor carter
please
thank you mr mayor um in my professional
role
i commission our domestic violence
services for manchester city council
so i ha i oversee our refuge provision
and our outreach and our specialist
services which include counselling for
children
lgbt services so it's a subject i'm
passionate about
and i want to talk about the impact of
the current pandemic
i'm going to start by paying tribute to
the wonderful services we have here in
trafford and in manchester
especially our colleagues working within
the council
trafford domestic abuse services the
manchester women's aide and sahili
who've all worked creatively and
relentlessly to support the survivors of
dvna locally
when we were told to stay home and stay
safe
that wasn't what many women wanted to
hear
we have seen during the pandemic a
perfect storm
the virus plus locked out down gave
perpetrators a tool they used for
coercion
manipulation and an increased level of
violence
between march and july 26 women and
girls were killed in dv
related incidents the oldest was 82 and
the youngest was two who was killed
alongside her mother and a four-year-old
sister
so as survivors were exposed to
worsening conditions
their access to support was restricted
specialist services were adapting to
homeworking and unable to offer
face-to-face support
and there was a genuine concern for the
sustainability of the sector
alongside the court system being
suspended leaving some women with
nowhere to go
and whilst to talk about women as we
know domestic violence is a gendered
crime
the bbc reported last week about the
number of men seeking help has jumped 60
percent during lockdown
and we know traditionally male victims
are really reluctant to seek support
so at this point i want to pay tribute
to ex-prime minister theresa may
which isn't something i say very often
because she brought the domestic
violence bill
to parliament but it's currently going
through the house of lords
but this was sadly delayed by the
illegal pro-roguing of parliament last
autumn
she understood the impact of domestic
abuse to the whole country
both socially emotionally and
financially
during the pandemic the government have
made various crisis funding pots
available
but these have all got to be spent by
october
so what happens then the impact of
covert 19
is already showing that we need a
longer-term solution to the
problem and one of those major problems
for women
in refuge is the difficulty of finding
somewhere else to move on to
and this isn't just a problem for them
we've seen it with homelessness people
with mental health substance use
also suffering the same challenges in
manchester we were able to work with our
colleagues in manchester move and
particularly councillor duffield
to enable many women to secure permanent
housing
but we're predicting a future spike in
demand for services
and austerity and unemployment are
likely to reduce the support available
which will increase the reliance on
services in what's already a challenging
fundraising landscape
the true impact will become clearer down
the line
but at the moment we all have a crucial
role to play
in raising awareness of abuse we call
upon the government to develop long-term
funding strategies to meet the increase
in demand
covered 19 has laid bare the lack of
protection and support for women and
children
and demonstrated the urgent need for
change
the bill must be underpinned by
sustainable funding for life-saving
specialist support services
if it's to make a real difference to
survivors lives
thank you mr mayor carter councillor
heinz please
thank you mr mayor um i think my
colleagues have made some really
powerful points
um this evening and i would like to
thank them
um actually for their for their
testimonies
um and i'll be quite brief um
so but i did want to speak in support of
the motion
particularly um in respect
to the impact of domestic violence on
children
and as members will know the motion was
deferred from the march meeting
um but i actually think it's now more
important than ever to highlight
domestic
abuse and to implement the actions set
out into the
in in the motion and to call for
effective funding from government
and the motion references the
devastating impact of domestic violence
on women
and it also mentions children living in
households where there is domestic
abuse we know that the prevalence of
children living with domestic abuse in
their lives is high
and we also know that percentages
percentages of children in need and lots
after children
who've been exposed to domestic abuse is
hugely significant
and heartbreakingly the coronavirus
crisis has led
to a dramatic surge in domestic abuse
locally there's been a strong
partnership approach with good examples
of creative practice
but we do know that lockdown and
restrictions has led to some
escalation in violence in the home and
that children
being out of school may prevented some
of this from being easily identified
being exposed to domestic abuse can
impact a child's life in every way
their self-esteem social development
educational attainment
and can lead to feelings of fear
confusion
powerlessness isolation and loneliness
and this impact can last a lifetime
to protect women and vulnerable children
it's vital that the council takes the
steps laid out in the motion
it's also critical for the government to
radically adequately support the
domestic abuse bill
and that this doesn't get lost amidst
the financial pressures of covid
as the motion states there is a huge
financial cost
to not adequately addressing domestic
abuse
but the human cost is far greater and i
urge all members to support the motion
thank you mr mayor thank you councillor
heinz councillor patel please
thank you mr mayor in december
2019 police chief superintendent john
sutherland
a serving officer of 25 years described
domestic violence as terrorism on an
epic scale
a disease of pandemic proportions and
the single greatest cause of harm in our
society
this poignant description is a rare
acknowledgement of the widespread impact
that domestic violence has in our
communities
for victims and for those that witness
violent or coercive control it can be a
lifelong sentence
the repercussions from this often hidden
crime runs through our adult and
children's social services
our schools prisons drug and alcohol
services homelessness
and places huge demands on nhs frontline
and mental health support
i welcome this motion and offer thanks
and support to
trafford domestic abuse service who have
seen demand soar through lockdown
they have responded amazingly under very
difficult circumstances
i would encourage everyone to take up
training in domestic violence awareness
and echo the call for adequate
government funding to support local
councils and partnership agencies
in tackling what is really is a national
emergency
thank you councillor brophy please
thank you mr mayor so i'm only going to
speak very briefly just to add the
liberal democrat group's support
wholeheartedly for this motion
we know from covid that all types of
mental health have got worse and from
the answer to the question
earlier the services are struggling on
this
in many regards and just like to add
praise to all the staff who are working
in this field there is no cost that
we shouldn't look at to make sure
these families always people
who aren't impacted by it
to go on the relevant training that's
been mentioned
also key to supporting people is having
joined up services and joined up
services that work across greater
manchester
with the police with with the agencies
that can support people and making sure
traffic has got
got those services there for when people
need them
i did think when we had the um slogans
from the government about
um stay home stay safe i did think
yes stay home stay safe but actually for
some people
staying at home is is not very safe for
at some times in our messaging i think
we need to think about the fact that
we don't always get it right with all
groups of people and
and those mental health services across
the board including for domestic
violence are just
so so important so just a few brief
words to add my support thank you very
much to all those who
remove the motion thank you councillor
brophy
um councillor mrs haddad finally please
you've muted yourself councillor haddad
thank you mr mayor i too would like to
support this motion
and and to say thank you to councillor
new for bringing this forward and i'm
immensely proud
of my party for championing
the dis the domestic abuse bill
it's a landmark piece of legislation
which will benefit many and as we know
we've all heard the cases that have
been raised over the pan over the time
of the pandemic
and and i particularly like to mention
the um the elderly population
who um age uk have said
there has been 40 increase over the last
two years
of those um
elderly population who are most
vulnerable
and um i hope that we
in trafford can remember them and
encourage our residents to help
in safeguarding that silent population
thank you mr mayor thank you councillor
mrs haddad
i've had two very brief indications and
that this will be the final speeches on
this
from uh very briefly please from
councillor evans to start with and then
councillor weston
councillor evans please thank you mr
mayor and i would i'd like to wear
i'd like to thank councillor new
councillor carr
and councillor carter for their
contributions this evening
thankfully for me i'm not qualified in
any way to speak on this topic
but you patently are and i thank you for
your contributions and our group
will wholeheartedly support this motion
councilor evans councillor weston please
thank you mr mayor just to advise that
council ms blackburn did indicate
earlier and he's currently waving at the
screen just so you're aware
mr mayor did indicate before myself and
councillor evans
all right i'll let her off i can't see
everybody's screen can everybody please
use the chat function if they can
carry on councillor western yeah thank
you mr mayor so just just
very very briefly um incredibly
powerful testimony as councillor heinz
said and i'm very very proud
um to have been able to listen to the
contributions that we've had tonight
councillor patel did briefly mention
tdas and i just wanted to um place on
record
my own tribute to them they celebrated
their uh 30th anniversary
this year they have provided incredible
support to victims of
um domestic abuse in trafford for all of
those 30 years and i know they've also
been
fortunate to be able to open a new
facility in the
this year sadly um needed but it is
incredibly incredibly important this
issue it's one that we know has been
exacerbated by lockdown but there has
been a stain on society often
an unspoken stain for many many years so
i'm really pleased
um that this motion has come tonight i
thank everybody who's contributed
and i'm really pleased and particularly
with appears that we have um got
cross-party support on what should never
ever be a political issue thank you mr
mayor
thank you councillor weston councillor
mr blackburn finally pleased
thank you thank you mr mayor um i fully
support this motion
as does the conservative group which
details the traffic partnerships
domestic violence
and abuse strategy and having worked in
social housing
in manchester uh and salford i've
witnessed many
instances of violence and abuse um
in trafford many residents live in
loving and respectful homes that results
in healthy happy lives and long may it
continue but
unfortunately there are significant
numbers where this is not the norm
and mainly women become the recipients
of trauma
inflicted by their spouses or partners
these vile uh
[Music]
these vile um uh perpetrators feel the
need to exert power
in a relationship that only they control
everyone should feel safe either at home
or amongst others in
our communities with family and friends
no woman
should ever have to feel the slap punch
kick
stamp or bite from the person who
purports to love them
no woman should be psychologically
belittled or prevented from interacting
with anyone
this sick and disturbing control
coercive control
may not be initially recognized and the
perpetrator
may just seem to be a loving but
overprotective spouse
or partner and this behavior is often
um evident towards the children
in recent times the tragic results of
coercive control has been
the murder of women and their children
no child or young person
should have to witness the results of or
actually experience
domestic violence or abuse the effects
will be lifelong
everyone here this evening everyone in
our communities must be made aware
of the personal impact of such criminal
and amoral behaviour on the recipients
which are mainly women
it's essential that the stigma of
violence and abuse is eradicated
and no woman with a black eye or broken
ribs should have to feel the need
to blame it on an open cupboard door or
a discarded child's toy on the floor no
woman should have to feel guilty for not
being good enough
no woman should have to keep quiet about
her spouse or partners
dirty little secrets all women
need to know that there is help
available and
our council has an obligation to work in
partnership
and to protect and support which we do
and we must always help
our vulnerable residents and have a zero
uh tolerance approach and i know
from from from our party that everybody
will support this motion
thank you thank you for letting me speak
thank you
um councillor knew you have the right of
reply
i'd just like to say thank you for the
support for this motion
and it's something that we really do
feel very passionately about in labor
groups so thank you very much
thank you councillor new i'm not
detecting that we're going to need to
put this motion to the vote
um can i assume everyone's agreement
that uh to carry this motion all right
[Music]
all right thank you very much everyone
hi hi that motion is therefore carried
and moving on motion 7b the second
motion this evening was also deferred
from the march meeting
and concerns responsible tax conduct and
i will add that
just being slightly conscious of time
and that we still have three motions to
get through
um obviously i was not going to limit
speeches on the given the subject matter
of the previous motion
however i would ask everybody apart from
the proposer and seconder
um and uh just to keep their speeches
um brief and to limit them to a minute
please
with that counselor ross would you
please move the first motion
thank you mr mayor and i will be brief
it gives me great pleasure to propose
this motion in support of the councils
for a fair tax declaration
one of the many consequences of the past
few months is the growing wish we all
have for a fear of society
and wanting to avoid going back to how
things were before the pandemic changed
our world
one of the ways the council can work
towards a better society is by joining
other real authorities
of different political colours including
oxford oldham
edinburgh peterborough and lincoln in
signing this declaration
celebrating and supporting companies
that pay their taxes in full
and not do business with companies that
participate in avoidance exercises
i cannot add much more the comprehensive
motion in front of colleagues
but hope the emotion receives unanimous
support thank you
thank you councillor ross council
accordingly i understand is seconding
the motion council accordingly
are you there thank you mr mayor i'm
sorry
i i can't get the um device to recognize
a camera
i've only just tried that uh i should
have sorted that out earlier
um with your forgiveness i i'll continue
i'm delighted to be given the
opportunity to second this labour group
motion
and signing up to the fair tax mark i'm
delighted because i was there at
its inception with the council executive
bringing ethical procurement into our
protocols was there at the start of this
labour administration
it's in our dna yes we want to go
further but we're giving a clear signal
of what we see as fair practice
the public are demanding a level playing
field and a fair lockdown
the idea of companies weaseling out of
pain into a pot
and then having the goal to make a claim
on covert support infuriated the
british public those companies are on
march time
if there's to be any brexit dividend we
would hope
to see it making global companies pay
their uk
tax but what about the companies that do
pay their taxes
why are they not benefiting a key aspect
of the fair tax mark is highlighting
responsible practice and the list of
companies that are applying for this
certification
is growing daily companies within reach
of
our northwest lives are being accredited
electricity north west
richard's richer sounds gleason the
builders
timpsons and many many more so it's
important that traffic gets itself on
board
i'm certainly proud that we're doing
this and to be in
this first vanguard of councils is
something for us all to be proud of
and i want to finish on this note
between 2014 and 2019
public procurement contracts within a
combined
value of 37.5 billion
were won by businesses with connections
to a tax haven
that's not just a loss to the public
purse it's a loss to all the rival
companies
who are doing the right thing by their
country but were
undercut by tax avoiders so don't be a
trump
support fair tax and support the motion
thank you mr mayor
thank you council accordingly i'm sure
none of us would want to be a trump
um councillor heinz just for full
disclosure wishes to declare an interest
as she works for her majesty's revenue
and customs
thank you for pointing that out
councillor heinz uh
councillor morgan please i believe you
want to speak
uh thank you mr mayor um given the
demands on time i'm not going over the
motion but the conservative group will
be supporting the motion tonight
uh both the context of it and the
pledges um
it's just really um a query really for
councillor ross
when he's doing his summing up um just
when we're looking at the implementation
of the pledges
and just reassurance on for small any
small businesses to look at any burden
that we do
put on them i'm i'm more than sure that
all the groups
represented tonight and um himself and
council accordingly
we want supporting small local
businesses especially at the moment and
we just don't want any approach which
could
um in terms of um council contracts
and thank you very much mr man
so much councillor morgan um i've
received no further indications
um oh councillor newgross would also
like to
uh support this motion on behalf of the
liberal democrats
um but i would also like to add that i
do
hope that the reach of this motion
is not only on our suppliers and
contracts but also
on the people we loan money to through
the investment fund
i hope that it reaches that far also
thank you thank you councillor new gosh
councillor coggins you've indicated
you'll be supporting do you need to
speak on that
or thank you very much um in which case
i'm not detecting again that we need to
put this motion to the vote
um councillor ross you have right of
reply
and then i will proceed councillor ross
thank you mr thank you first of all to
uh councillor morgan councillor new
gross
and to council coggins for confirming
support of the other parties that's
that's really good news i completely
take on board what you say
counselor morgan about or small
businesses i am pretty sure that they
will all be following and be exemplars
anyway
in terms of um of paying their tax and
being responsible
but i am mindful that you know they have
been through a lot
this year and are set to go through more
sadly and yes it does extend to the
investment management board as well this
uh
for future reference but other than that
thank you very much everyone
thank you councillor ross um with that
as i say i'm not hearing any naysays so
can i
take it that that motion is carried by
i i i
i i
um moving on then um with that motion
carried the third motion
uh concerns the financial impact of
covid on local authority budgets
uh and is to be moved understand by the
leader of the council
councillor weston please yeah thank you
mr mayor colleagues will be unsurprised
to hear that the
financial impact of the kobe crisis has
been
incredibly challenging for ourselves in
trafford not only
in terms of um the impact that it has
had on the lives of our residents in
financial terms as well as all of the
other
um impacts that they have suffered from
and but also on the
council's bottom line and you know with
that in mind it was incredibly
heartening
given that this was inevitable in many
ways to hear
um the government making positive noises
of whatever it takes
at the start of the crisis to meet the
financial pressures that this would
cause for
local authorities and i say that
cognizant the fact that there is not a
single
area of our council's functions that has
not
been touched by this no area of our
service delivery
that has not had to change to adapt to
increase its support or to do things
differently as a result of this crisis
it has had
far-reaching consequences for the local
authority as it has for all of our
residents and i'd like to begin really
by saying an enormous thank you to each
and every one of our fantastic staff
here in trafford who
six months into this continue to do us
incredibly proud and i'm sure i speak
for all members when i say an enormous
thank you
um to them and it is not only in
trafford mr mayor that we see
the enormous impact that the crisis has
had it has had a monumental impact on
council budgets up and down
the country council budgets of course
that are already stretched to the limit
after 10 years of
sustained austerity so it is not
hyperbole really to say that
this crisis has the potential indeed
some would say it already has brought
local authorities to their knees um
and in spite of that background of
sustained
austerity and troubling finances the
whatever it takes narrative soon shifted
towards talk of
initially burden sharing um
and then um the somewhat suspect
decision
slightly improved upon since but no
nowhere near enough
to suggest that only costs would be
covered rather than
lost income and that for any local
authority but particularly
for a local authority such as ourselves
who have always been
incredibly innovative in our approach is
a really concerning
fact because it means that the enormous
amount of income that we bring in
um to the council um the loss
of this as a result of things such as
parking charges just as one example
and punches a huge hole in our budget
um and it's not as though the government
aren't aware mr mayor of the extent of
this we
as with all of the councils have been
reporting regularly to
mhclg on the overall cost of kobit
in trafford and in terms of this
financial year alone
um 20 20 21 that amounts to more than 45
million pounds and i'm sure that
councillor evans would point out if i
did not
that we have received some contribution
towards meeting the cost of that
um so we had received um
a total of 28.65 million pounds
predominantly
um in the form of uh just over 12
million of various
specific ring fence grants and then 13.1
million pounds of direct support to
to meet the costs of the crisis but that
still
leaves us with in total a 17 million
pound funding challenge
in year that is something that
although it is incredibly difficult we
hope that we can
achieve in terms of dealing with without
in year cuts but it also
leaves us with a huge problem next year
with
over 15 million pounds of
um top up to our existing funding
challenge that we that we all knew about
when we set
the balanced budget that we did in
february we always knew that next year
would be incredibly challenging and to
have to find a further more than 15
million pounds as a result of the
covid crisis means that the future of
our
services it would not be hyperbole to
suggest
is incredibly very bleak indeed
it means that we have an overall
financial challenge in trafford now for
20 21 22 of 37 and a half
million pounds um that is a
staggering figure and it is even more
staggering when you consider everything
that we are having to do
and look set to need to continue to do
for some time yet in response to
this unprecedented crisis and so the
motion mr mayor
um simply seeks to raise awareness of
that
and to call upon government to fully
meet
the financial implications of covid or
trafford
not to renege on its promise to do
whatever it takes but to recognize the
wide reaching impact
not only that this has had but that not
funding does properly
in terms of recompense for that will
have on services for the residents of
trafford moving forward and it's on that
basis mr mayor but i would ask all
members to support the motion thank you
i understand the motion will be seconded
by councillor ross
councillor ross please yes seconded mr
man i reserve the right to speak
thank you councillor ross i've had an
indication councillor newgrosh
first please
thank you mr mayor i would just like to
echo uh
councillor weston our leader there um we
in good faith at trafford council
responded amazingly
to the covid crisis we did everything
and more that we could have been asked
of
and we have been left mostly to foot the
bill
it is deeply unfair and
i fully support this request to
government
to cover the costs and the losses that
we have
for our response it is it is the right
thing
and we echo that thank you
thank you councillor newgross councillor
coggins please
thank you chair i want to start by
echoing both cancer western and council
new goshes uh thanks to
officers and indeed members who have had
to deal with
um a mind-blowing financial crisis on
top of the health and social care crisis
that we've been handling
and and as council new gosh has said we
have seen some really constructive cross
party and all party working and and
that's enabled us
as group leaders to see firsthand really
the the yawning
chasm that has opened up in in our
finances and
and and see the the challenge really
that officers and
members have faced and as greens we
are fully supportive of this motion we
do believe that government has to do
whatever it takes to make sure that no
one is left behind as we recover from
this crisis
and we need to think about who the
economy is for and what the economy is
for
and it's got to be there to give us the
best lives that we could possibly
possibly can do and i'd like to add to
what's here
actually really government needs to be
thinking now as many governments around
the world please counselor coggins if
you can please
about universal basic income because we
need security
for all our people as we transform our
economy to do it not just the covert
crisis but also the climate emergency
so thank you thank you thank you
councillor coggins
councillor evans please
thank you mr mayor um it's a terrible
shame this
uh this motion to be fair and nobody's
disputing there's been a
horrendous impact uh on council finances
um but it comes this i could have pre we
could have predicted this notion a
couple of months ago
our leader was uh suggesting that the
council was bankrupt
and and potentially uh declaring a
section 114 notice
um such a degree that the council has to
write to its own staff to reassure them
that this was not
not happening and this motion goes
uh far too far in demanding
um the replacement of all losses
that the council might make because of
coving and we are not even at that point
of even knowing the government has said
they will support councils
and they will replace fees i'm looking
at it on the screen there
and that has been the introduction of an
income loss scheme which will come
compensate for every couple of an
irrecoverable and
all unavoidable police councilman sales
and fees
and this motion simply attempts to
saddle the government with
losses however derived and
no matter what this council does and and
the same applies to all other councils
councillor evans councillor dr carr
please
thanks chair um covered 19 has already
had a terrible negative impact on both
mental and physical
health there's been an increase in
isolation mental health crises
a marked increase in alcohol use and
alcohol related health issues
and worsening obesity the there are
already signs that the covert 19
crisis has had a disproportionate effect
on those who are already disadvantaged
never have our green spaces leisure
services
early years and public health
improvement measures been more important
this is the worst possible time to be
having to make savage cuts to services
and it is criminal for government
to not provide the help to councils
which is so desperately needed
to have to consider cuts at the level
required to maintain the budget a time
when residents need these services the
most is absolutely heartbreaking
we really need this help thank you
councillor dr carr councillor lally
please
that's true with this
promotion unfortunately um yeah
corvids cost a huge amount of money all
of
the birthdays as colleagues
described the comfortability that i have
with this particular
is is in one particular line uh
version that this executive is putting
forward
is the council should launch a
communication campaign
like similar authorities now you're
suggesting that we're short of cash
already
and to solve that problem is to to
highlight it by a communications
campaign i don't like the way that
the different political parties are
using code for their own ends
and this motion sums up a nutshell
i'm sorry i can't thank you councillor
lally
um councillor ross please
thanks mr man thank you mr mayor i'd
just like to
come back in following particularly
councillor evans comments there um
i'm a bit concerned with what he said uh
he seems to think we're
we're threatening and being political
about the the threat of a section 114 i
have to say to colleagues it still is
a threat that has not gone away we have
still got a budget hole
this year that we are looking to bridge
and officers are working round the clock
at ways of doing that including using
some of our reserves to
to help bridge that gap so this isn't
just a
political gesture or a stunt we have
looked at our finances we have looked at
ways the best we can
within trafford to bridge the um to
bridge the
growing um budget gap and when i look
ahead to next year
i see a a chart and it has the biggest
budget gap we have seen in the 10 years
we have had to go through our studies
comments up please counsel
all i would say is we have um we have
already seen so many
services stripped from this council and
we have a very real risk of more
being under threat unless this
government delivers thank you councillor
ross
councillor brophy please
and that was for motion d mr mayor an
early indication
yeah thank you councillor hartley then
thank you mr mayor i'd i'd like to fully
support this motion
councilor evans said that it was a
terrible shame that this motion had to
be brought but
really what's a terrible shame here is
that the government have not delivered
on their promise to do whatever it takes
to put cancels in the in the position
that they were before before kobe had
hit us
and i know cancer lally questioned the
need for the
communications campaign that is
mentioned in the motion
i think that's very necessary so that
residents are fully aware of where
responsibility for this funding crisis
that we see in local governments where
that really lies i know a lot of
residents
will will will say and a lot of
residents say to me their council tax is
going up
year on year so why are the council in
this position
well residents need to know that their
council tax doesn't cover
the council's expenditure council tax
raises about 100 million
and the revenue budget of the council is
175 million
we've never seen a funding gap uh like
this at trafford
and it's clear where the responsibility
lies everything that
everything the national government has
done on kobit has been a disaster
and the council has been at the
forefront of helping residents out
throughout this pandemic and it's right
that local government should be properly
funded to do that thank you mr
councillor hartley councillor mrs haddad
[Music]
please
thank you mr mayor um i'd just like to
say that
um we're all in agreement that this
uh unprecedented
has cost a huge amount
um to support our
country and i i can't
um agree with councillor stanley when he
says that everything
the government has done has been a
disaster i mean
you know one one hears daily on the
national news
how the furlough scheme has been
so um so um
so what's with sorry stopwood for a
moment and
it's been i supported so many people and
has been
um an extraordinary um
initiative by our government and
i don't i further like to say to
councillor ross
that um police council yeah
councillor ross that the um reserve
money is my understanding that
some of it has been used i mean is is
the reserve money not
for crisis such like as this that we
thank you councillor i think we've got a
message there
um councillor freeman i've had um
uh no it says speak please i'm not sure
if that's an instruction to me or a
request
anywhere you're on
thank you mr mayor i couldn't sit here
and listen any longer to some of the
things we're getting from our opposition
uh conservative councillors um
i think council hartley summed it up
everything this government has done
on covid has been an outright disaster
it is the local authority that's
delivered everything
and they are selling us short in terms
of supporting us with the finance and
the money that we need
and anyone who sits there tonight and
says that's not true
well i'm sorry you know look it look it
look in the mirror
look in the mirror we've been let down
badly and we need this support now from
government if we're going to close this
gap
thank you very much mr mayor
i have no further indications
uh therefore councillor weston you have
the right of reply
yeah thank you mr mayor i'll start by
thanking both
the green and liberal democrat groups
for their support for this motion which
is
one of the most important motions that
that we could be bringing to
council given the scale of the financial
challenge that we that we face and i
couldn't agree more with councillor
evans
that it is a terrible shame that we felt
we need to bring it but when we have
been left high and dry
and when we face a 17 million pound
after government support financial
challenge this year
and a top up to our already austerity
written budget challenge next year of
more than 15 million pounds
that leaves us in real strife
the financial impact of cobit on this
council this year's 45 million pounds
that's more than a quarter of our
revenue budget so
i'm sorry but this is absolutely
necessary and to sound scandalized at
the suggestion
that all our losses should be replaced
of course they should and you reference
the scheme that doesn't compensate for
all of our losses
it does not it compensates 75 above the
first five percent so i suggest you
check your facts on that counselor
evidence
as for whatever the council does no
directly related to covid and we have to
prove
that and i just say also very briefly
that i
i would disagree with councillor freeman
when he said everything's been done by
the local authority
um and pay tribute to our health
partners who worked incredibly hard
um in the ccg and in the nhs alongside
us and in true partnership which has
been fantastic to see
and also make sure that the council does
not have its fingerprints anywhere on
the most failing aspect of the corona
virus response which is track and trace
of course
which is not even nhs tracking trace let
alone local trust and traffic tracer is
circo
track and trace and it is these national
centralized and privatized solutions
that have let us down in this
whilst local authorities have been at
the forefront and are now paying the
price
so i'd urge all members to support the
motion and i'd like a recorded vote
please mr matt
thank you councilor weston um with that
we will move to a vote
um fabiola are we uh
yes we're ready when when you are sir
fair enough
um now the council leader did ask for a
recorded vote and
i think people will have to indicate
visually that's going to be rather
difficult given that
not everybody's got the camera on um
i think mr mayor the the fact is that uh
as the
vote we can get a full report of how
people are voted it's whether we're
actually able to make it available
in the course of the meeting we can
publish it subsequently
um the way that the process works it
will record
exactly who has voted in which way and
we will then be able to publish that
that's perfectly is yeah thank you jane
well that's good to know
um in which case we will move to the
vote fabiola um
if you could please put the uh matter to
the vote and
all members if you could um press the
button on the little box and if you
don't get a little box
please indicating the chat function what
you voted
has everybody um had that i've had one
person counselor thomas
saying he didn't get a box up but he's
voting in favor can you please note that
as well fabio
yes i will so uh in favor mr mayor we've
gone
38 members plus country thomas
to 39 against we've got 14
members and
no obtain thank you very much
in which case the motion is carried
thank you very much
and the uh details will be published
later on
uh moving on oh there we go and it's
been shared on the box there
smashing moving on
motion 7d the final motion this evening
concerns lower speeds safer roads and to
be moved by councillor welton
please thank you very much mr mayor um
firstly i want to thank all the members
who've had input
into this motion which has uh evolved
considerably since
march i think we can all agree that
lower speed limits save lives but
debates on the effectiveness of 20 mile
an hour limits have been heard in our
chamber many times before
so i want to talk about the future and
why technological change in our vehicles
will make 20 mile an hour limits
a successful cost-effective tool that
will increase safety on our roads and
encourage more people to walk and cycle
in line with our commitments to tackle
the public health clean air and climate
emergencies
from 2022 all new models of vehicle will
come fitted with compulsory speed
limiters and data recorders
from 2024 all new vehicle all new
vehicles will be required to have them
the legislation comes from europe but
then most of our cars do as well
so this technology will be in our
vehicles even if our government changes
its mind about
incorporating it into uk rules for the
first time
there will be a large measure of
self-enforcement of speed limits built
into our vehicles
if your vehicle doesn't have it one in
front likely will
slowing you down anyway if you don't
believe this will change driver behavior
consider that one million drivers in the
uk have already chosen
to have a black box fitted in their car
in exchange for lower insurance rates
so insurance companies recognize the
value of this technology and so should
we
to properly benefit from it we need to
move on from the council's current
piecemeal approach to 20 mile an hour
limit
are we seriously going to put 20 mile a
mile an hour signs up
on hundreds of residential and school
streets how many tros and consultations
is that going to take and what's it
going to cost are we happy ending up
with a confusing
patchwork where the limit changes from
street to street or where
where a child riding to school is
protected near the school gate
but not on the rest of their journey so
let's listen to our residents about
where they want lower limits most
urgently while planning for a default 20
mile an hour limit so that all
residential roads school streets and
town centres are covered
as one fellow member said to me
yesterday i can only think of four roads
in my ward that need to be above 20
miles an hour
most of our roads are residential so
let's start making the change now and
remember while we're doing it
when i was riding my back to school in
1991 there were 20 million vehicles on
our streets
in 2022 when my son becomes a teenager
there will be 40 million these vehicles
are bigger heavier faster
and if electric quieter rat running on
what should be quiet residential streets
has doubled thanks to the sat nav in
every vehicle or phone
it is not no surprise that traffic
casualties are rising again
20 mile an hour limits are good enough
for conservative westminster
labor birmingham and 40 other councils
the whole of wales will be default 20
miles an hour by 2023
we are in danger of being left behind 20
miles an hour is something that can work
for everyone
it doesn't stop anyone driving anywhere
doesn't reduce road space
and has a negligible impact on journey
times but it will save lives and give
people the confidence to make healthy
travel choices we are asking them to
make
i urge you to support this motion
unamended
councillor i understand councillor
jerome is seconding this council jerome
i am uh seconding this motion and i'd
just like to uh
speak i've been the ultringham's 20s
plenty lead for many years also a local
campaigner
and of course now a councillor during
this time i've had hundreds of
conversations with residents about road
safety
i've spoken to elderly who tell me of
their terror crossing roads when
speeding cars can be so unpredictable
i speak to families who want to cycle to
their local
school or park but just aren't prepared
to face that danger
and of course myself my daughter now
recently at secondary school sets off
alone each morning
and i fear every time she crosses park
road in timperley
and for all the children facing so many
other such roads across the borough
i know how fast those cars travel in
their desperation to get from a to b
20 mile per hour speed limits are now
internationally recognized
they're the government's prescribed
option for local councils
wales is set to become 20s by default
this will help reduce
air pollution promote active travel and
can be part of a set of measures
that can help to change our culture and
help eliminate
that speeding mentality i'm proud
of the motion that michael councillor
wilson has put forward
it strives to give residents a say in
the streets that they live in
it aims to utilize sources of funding
that will minimise the cost to the
council
it asks to establish mechanisms
mechanisms by which safer streets can be
delivered
to those that most need them it also
doesn't stop at residential streets
and would look to pacify our town
centres too there are many good reasons
to support this
we know that lib dems will support us on
this and maybe some of
the blues will also however this motion
will rest on our labour colleagues to
the labour member
who wants 20s plenty and shined in our
emerging local plan
and the many labor uh members who listen
to the overwhelming voice of residents
in their wards probably day in day out i
ask you to vote with your values tonight
i would ask you along with all members
to support michael's motion unamended
thank you chair thank you councillor
jerome
um i understand councillor outside has
given notice he wishes to move an
amendment to the motion i'm going to
have to limit all speakers to a minute
from now
councillor ad said thank you mr mayor uh
and
as i'm moving in a moment i get more
than one minute i assume
no counselor we're running out of time
you're going to have to stick to a
minute we're 35 minutes
okay mr mayor uh obviously can't do a
lot in one minute mr mayor
but obviously the motion as it stands
can't be supported
because it has in accuracy and it's very
misleading
that now schemes do work because of
traffic calming without traffic calming
they will not be adhered to and it will
lead to residents actually uh
not being happy suggesting that you can
simply put it in with signs that does
not work now mr may it might be in
15 years 18 years time 20 years time
when everybody has some of these
vehicles that that that may be
self-complied with but unfortunately
that's a lot to possibly one two decades
off
so it's not really acceptable i also
think obviously the petition the police
is all quite clear
any 20 zones have to be self-enforcing
and that is a standard response
they are very clear that that is how it
has to be now i think
there's a number of problems with this
uh uh motion mr mayor
and obviously the original word suggests
that people can demand the scheme and
not the magic money favorite will
provide it this is wrong
all teams have to be paid for within
financial constraints we cannot use the
etf monies
because as uh the councils fully well
know that is
schemes that have made for on bids and
all those bids have actually have
fully subscribed now and they the scheme
along those bits
are being implemented worsen also
suggests that schemes cannot be asked
for
again this is inaccurate and misleading
and like all safety schemes
they can be requested and considered
alongside other schemes through a
variety of old safety measures
that help make up the capital program
that said i'm sure councillor western
can continue your point
yeah just finish off mr martin why not
simply say the labour group has a proud
and long record of supporting 20 zones
across the border and my own ward in
stratford and bradfield had the very
first one implemented some third council
had said you've been out arguably
concise as usual councillor
weston you have the right to second this
again a minute please
i'm second in reserve for now thank you
thank you councillor weston that's noted
um councillor brophy please
so it will become no surprise to fellow
councillors that the liberal democrat
group
are supporting this motion
wholeheartedly in fact i'm using a
recycled speech be quiet again counselor
[Music]
i'm using a recycled speech here from
2012
when the liberal democrats first
proposed this as a motion
as the other councillors proposing this
motion have said trafford is in danger
of being left behind
now is the time that we put this into
effect now is the time when we promote
walking and cycling
due to climate change due to wanting
people to exercise due to social
distancing
and the kovic crisis we should not waste
any more time the figures have not
changed
in all this time being struck by a car
at 35 miles an hour still means a
shocking 50
chance of survival at 30 miles per hour
it there's still a 45 chance of being
killed
and this jumps to 20 miles per hour the
survival rate is 97
the figures speak for themselves but i
also think that isn't just about
having um you know road pumps and all
those kind of things
it does need to have traffic calming
measures that are supported
by residents that local people need to
have a say
and i think therefore now's the time
let's support this
implementation of a 20 mile per hour
proposal from trafford
i hope we get all party support and i
hope that trafford moves forward with
this motion
thank you councillor evans please
thank you mr mayor i think we've had a
bigger debate in our group
on this than we've had on anything and
i've just written down here we debated
this three years ago actually obviously
thank you jane
elect debated this eight years ago and
and
i personally was quite passionate with
respect to the original green motion but
i think as a group will support the
labour amendment because it allies some
of the fears of some of our members but
i do worry and i have
expressed this to councillor weltson
that it becomes a bit of a sock this
amendment
and so if it's a genuine commitment from
the administration
to do these reviews and deliver for next
march
and quite happily support it i would
like to see that some really
ham-fisted amateur attempts recently i
appreciate we've
been under a lot of pressure that i have
vocally been against i would love to get
behind some proper
well thought out constructive schemes
that are not going to interrupt
general traffic flow and that are going
to support our residents so
we will as a group hopefully support
this promotion
at this the sorry the amendment and as
opposed to the motion
so thank you thank you and let's hope we
can deliver on it we have to
present a petition to the boys
thank you thank you mr mayor members
will appreciate that it's rare that i
actually speak at full
council however this is one such
occasion
it's now over six years since myself the
then councillors pam dixon and david
higgins
met with the then executive member
responsible for highways
the officers similarly responsible and
the local police inspector discussed
issues entrapment first among these was
the matter of controlling speed
and utterly unreasonable root usage in
the ward
many residents and fellow members will
know that i have consistently been an
advocate
for the introduction of lower speed
limits in large parts of the most
residential areas
of brooklyn's ward and other parts of
the borough
accordingly i very much welcome the
ability to support
any initiative which might bring such
introductions
whether this is the amended motion or
the original motion thank you mr mayor
boys we are now over the time allotted
for this meeting
jane can you advise the legal position
please
i can't hear you
i i think that we can probably move to a
vote on the amendment sorry
uh a lot of time do we
i have to finish it night right
sorry i i i was working on the basis
that we were going through till 9 30
which was the old time sorry that's my
fault
um if that's the case then i think that
you need to take a vote
on the um amendment if members are
happy to do so i think that would be
acceptable in the current circumstances
um given that the arrangements are
effectively a temporary arrangement but
i think we can vote in this particular
circumstance
if we have any um leeway at all to
extend the time slightly
i think i i think if members
are happy to do so then i think that
given that
our normal time would be 9 30 i
personally would be quite um agreeable
to the matter going
forward to 9 30 i wasn't aware that we'd
actually curtailed it
at nine um i i don't recall that
so i'm apparently that it continues to 9
30.
thank you councillor weston right in
that case if everybody's happy with that
i will take councillor morgan please
thank you mr mayor but i will still keep
uh very brief um
council evans has already um disclosed
our group position
um and um but i think i i'm i've been
pretty supportive of this when i saw um
councilor welton's proposal
um um and i i'm not gonna go into do you
have to mean whether
speed limiters or enforce this or
signs but what i actually would say is
even on some of the roads that i think
maybe would
stay at 30 miles an hour and i'm
thinking of grove lane in my ward and
delahaye's
um road i've seen people drive at 45
pushing 50 or that's my
best estimate and if it just drags
people down 10 miles an hour down
that must be a good thing um thank you
thank you councillor morgan um
councillor coggins i know you've asked
in the chat for a recorded vote but
don't necessarily wish to speak
again fabiola can that be noted please
yes mr mayor
thank you very much um councillor
right um does any other councillors wish
to speak then
nope right um in which case um
councillor welton you of course have the
right
oh councillor weston i beg your pardon
you did reserve the right didn't you
carry on
yeah thank you mr mayor so councillor
i've had
the reasons for the amendment around
deliverability around addressing
inaccuracies in the current
um way in which we go about the
implementation of 20 mile an hour zones
um and and on that basis the labour
group position is to support the
amendment thank you mr mayor i don't
need to say any more than that
thank you very much councillor weston um
councillor welton
um as with the previous motions i'll
give you a couple of minutes to
respond to the points and um
reply thank you very much thank you very
much mr mayor um i do welcome the
constructive elements of um this uh
amendment i hope that the the report
that is to be published will
be a chance to reflect on the new techno
technological realities because i think
uh councillor ads head certainly needs
to read up on them at uh
2019 was a bad year for car sales
but even that even at those levels
one-third of the cars on our roads by
the end of the decade
will have speed limiting technology
fitted and
that will have major implications
because as i say that means one of the
cars in front of you if you don't have
the technology
will have it and it will be slowing them
down okay
i also welcome the commitment to improve
the right of residence to request
changes to their local roads
because there is currently nothing on
the council website that explicitly says
they can do
this nor is the matrix by which such
respect requests are judged available in
an
obvious format so though you may say
that this is available how is it
available if people don't actually know
about it if there's no
if there if there's no obvious um
published
mechanism um for this so i hope that you
will deal with this
but we will be voting against the
amendment because we believe it's no
longer time for harsh
measures with regards to road safety
public health or the climate emergency
cities across the uk are moving ahead
with 20 mile an hour limits most
recently manchester city council
is going to has proposed 20 zones
uh 20 zone in the city center last week
our own public health director led
on a manifesto advocating 20 mile an
hour limits on residential streets
we can make this step tonight and get on
with it by rejecting this amendment
and i urge fellow members to do so thank
you very much
thank you very much councillor welton um
a recorded vote has been asked for um
therefore we will move to the vote um
fabiola are you all set up to do that
yes mr mayor
thank you so um just to clarify this is
a vote on the amendment and is a
recorded vote
so does everybody wish to indicate
please
again if anybody hasn't got the box on
their screen please indicate their vote
in the chat
function on zoom
okay if that's if everybody has voted i
can
uh we've just got one councillor thomas
he's voting for the amendment but
doesn't have his box and can you count
him please
okay so i'll show the results now mr
mayer
okay so we've got in favor of the
amendment
for plus 143
and then against seven and
abstain uh two
people uh let me share the talk with you
okay so the amendment is carried
that amendment is carried and therefore
becomes the
substantive motion um does anybody wish
to speak on the substantive motion
um you again you'll have a minute but
i'll just wait if anybody wants to
indicate
nope definitely silence right in which
case
um i will put the substantive motion to
the vote
um again fabio are you ready to uh
do the poll yes mr mayor uh
on now again if everybody could indicate
and just pop on the chat function if
they don't get a box in front of you
okay mr mayor thank you again fabiola
councillor thomas seems to be boxless
so um and he's voting in favor of the
substantive motion
yeah thank you just waiting for
everybody to vote
yep okay
okay okay i think everybody
bought it now i'll show the results uh
mr mayor
so we've got 45 plus
one members in favor
for again and to
abstain thank you very much fabio
that motion is therefore carried
um thank you again to all the speakers
um and thank you for bearing with me i
think we've had a good meeting
um can i therefore thank everyone for
their attendance at this evening's
meeting
i know it's always a little bit
difficult on zoom but
um everybody is just still doing a good
job out there um representing their
communities
and keeping everybody informed so to all
members and to all the public out there
please do stay safe
do look after yourselves and all being
well
i will see you at the meeting
at the end of next month thank you thank
you